dank der miteinander umgeht sollte damen
und herren i visited eingeblendet diese
welt verändern den geschmack von wasser
zu collatz orangensaft megatrucks das
sind zwei wächter von der marke light
cup jetzt ist nicht folgen sollten
ich bekomme kein geld für aber das hört
sich mega man das hier ist der becher
namens orange labour und dass sie ist
der becher namens cola flavour hier
steht heute sogar die sensation auf
fledermäuse kombination also ihr
werkstoff der englische marke also leute
hier steht drauf haut und workstation
noch viele weiße combination of sales
and zeit also wie sinne des geschmacks
filme kombination vom schmecken
ich war noch nicht gut irgendwie chef
scott carson aus picks the floor roc
kidz hektisch
everything that can get it on the water
drinking experience also es soll wohl so
funktionieren dass dieser becher nicht
nur das wasser liegend wie den geschmack
verändert sondern richtigen geruch des
bechers denkt man da das eine
kombination aus schmecken und riechen
ist der das vivo rcs linken seite von
john travolta kriegt doch abonnieren
freunde alter ich habe mein gott walther
der ist ja cool kräftig
da ist nicht mal was drin also nicht um
wachstum festgestellt ist sich
tatsächlich wie wasser als leuchtet es
fall einfach in die spieler das ist so
schade dass wir das jetzt nicht
irgendwie den cup hoch legen wir euch
natürlich haben leute wie es das bei der
versammlung ein bisschen scheiße ich
will eigentlich die welt offen ich
glaube ich es erst mit dem orangen
welche hier mit leitungswasser sogar
noch weiter ich habe jetzt leider kein
scheiß
es riecht einfach sind ist nicht besser
als von t ich trinke jetzt einfach mal
schlug
[Musik]
ja es ist schwierig zu beschreiben der
schmeckt so ein bisschen so wie wenn man
war sein vater hat und man fühlt dann
aber in die fan sein doch so ein
bisschen leitungswasser rhein sowie halt
fanta wassereis phasen wir sind mit dem
mit dem kunden hier wirklich nicht nur
eins ja divison geschmolzenes cola
wasser als okay das kann sein dass der
rand auch so ein bisschen auch noch sein
flavour geschmack hat irgendwie also ich
habe jetzt hier einmal fernseher und
einmal cola die sache jetzt ich würde
das beides jetzt mal raus will und unter
normalen straßenreifen oder gucken ob
das irgendwas am wasser gerade dank man
verändert hat er habe nicht doch kriegen
wir jetzt hier sei nur mit tricks es
nicht wirklich nach metzingen leute ich
bin ich bin ich bin beeindruckt
natürlich ist klar das ist jetzt nicht
irgendwie wasser wo das wasser darin
eine die farbe verändern schmeckt ist
also kratzer sondern es spielt natürlich
so ein bisschen mit den geschmacksträger
highlight freuen konnte sich auch die
gewicht die beiden augen sind und was
ist wenn wir das mal mit milch testen
der kraft wenn die auch noch von seinem
becher hätten der täglich kakao
geschmack
manchmal jeder das komplette wasser raus
ich fühle mich ein bisschen milch hier
eindeutig ihr seht schon milch in einem
communique hilft erstmal wie ich es gibt
es riecht nach cola und schmeckt noch
milch also ich glaube mir ich hatte
schon so ein verkratzen eigentlich mag
dass das nicht übertönt werden kann mich
im cola geschmack kannst du dir auch bei
der kombination aus million cola gedacht
hätte ich ihnen morgen so schmeckt
tatsächlich nur noch mit jetzt können
wir das ganze halt auch noch mal
probieren in dem wir nicht langsam
verfallen sondern wirklich irgendwie
weil sie nicht folgen oder jordan
irgendwie sowas steht jetzt auch vom
netzwerk also fühlen wir jetzt einfach
mal weg wasser hier schön in den
römischen das ist das orange klettern
und ihr gefährt das heißt die sache
geschmeckt überhaupt nicht auf orange
schmeckt einfach nur nach panzer die
können das einfach fand ableger nennen
da spreche leitungswasser kratzer ab
wenn man es ein fairer preis nun für die
lupe pfizer hier sehen wir schon kleine
sneak peek war die renten auf der
bildbetrachtung kennt
[Musik]
wir lassen jetzt auf jeden fall diesen
oliver du bist einfach wasser in diesem
leitthema drin stehen
das heißt die leute wenn ihr wollt dass
sich wetter noch ein zweites video mal
den wir jetzt machen und mir vielleicht
auch zwei andere geschmacksrichtungen
bestelle ich richtig nur orange und cola
sondern es gibt noch 674 andere
geschmacksrichtungen es gibt auch glaube
ich noch kaffee und energydrinks gibt
verschiedene sorten leute wenn ich das
aber testen soll schreibt während die
kommentare das leider wurden dann
schauen wir im nächsten video auf unsere
branche geworden ist auf jeden fall
wirklich mega kraft also mir war
wirklich zu beginn direkt klar okay das
ist jetzt nicht irgendwie was das
getränken an sich verändern und dann
haben die geschmacksnerven so ein
bisschen verwirrt und ich meine
entwickelt das ist wirklich das ist das
richtige know ich habe auf meine schuhe
geklettert wie findet ihr bei der neuen
schuhe die sie ich würde jetzt ein test
ist auch leute aber das muss man aus
amerika bestellen damit soll das ist
eine gewisse scheiße wenn leute mir
gefallen hat gesagt dass leicht schreibt
mir die kommentare reid kam
wenn ich das noch mal testen soll und
leute pizza von mir kommt am 15 10 aus
ihr habt schon kleinen tiefer gesehen
was das event für seine arbeit nicht nur
das video
[Musik]